it's the end of an era Trevor Noah quits
The Daily Show after walkery saw a
viewing figures slumped to around 363
363
000 a show seven years were taking over
from Jon Stewart who routinely pulled in
an audience of 1.5 million yeah I do
think wilkry played a role but I also
think it's just a change in how media is
being consumed I think Jon Stewart was
the real talent Trevor Noah was kind of
a nobody so he couldn't really pull
anything in yeah and also who's going to
be watching this year yeah Jon Stewart
built that show Trevor Noah just
inherited it uh but this is but this is
still good news yes I think Trevor Noah
was was bad he had half truths and
misinformation consistently on his show
that he wouldn't fact check and uh these
are the kind of people that believed
Russia gate Ukraine gate hands up don't
shoot Ahmed Arbury you know the Trayvon
Martin stuff they believed all the lies
the manipulations
so seeing him go
I was talking about this earlier
it is the end of an era the corporate
establishment the woke establishment
they are dwindling James Corden is that
his name that guy he's out yeah canceled
she's out did Gordon quit I think he
quit uh Trevor Noah quit he is quitting
he has he's not out yet but he's
announced his departure from the show
and so good there who are they going to
get this is effectively the end of this
of this trash Jon Stewart may have had
something back in the day but he created
this breed of mechanical formulaic fake
political humor that has plagued this
country for a decade so I'm glad to see
Trevor Noah out hopefully things like
this start to spread out and downturn
hopefully there's more of this I mean
you think about Jon Stewart destroyed
Crossfire you remember that that's right
right and Crossfire at the time he was
like this is partisan hackery we can do
so much better and it's like Crossfire
was the last time you had Republicans
and Democrats regularly debating each
other on equal terms
Jon Stewart comes in smug as a button
and says this is garbage and mock stock
Carlson and what does what is Jon
Stewart's Legacy garbage formulaic trash
humor you get it John Oliver it's the
current year little Timothy yes it's
like it's it's all it's not just that
it's that somebody uh somebody actually
wrote out the formula for John John
Oliver's Show and it was like say thing
compare it to thing in the past say what
year it is then say Timothy and it was
like you're like wow he actually does
that like half the time that's crazy and
then it was like they mentioned there
would be beats with claps from the
audience like and it was his meme that
was talking about how this was basically
programming people say thing call it
absurd whether it's true or not tell the
audience to clap for it
that's John Stewart's Legacy Samantha B
all that stuff gone good yeah and it was
it's all been terrible like Jon Stewart
was like the original and I remember Jon
Stewart being pretty funny at times like
he actually had real talent but God the
derivatives of Jon Stewart were so bad
The Echoes of Stuart yeah The Colbert
Report plague horror I thought it was so
bad he was pretending to be a war monger
and you couldn't tell if he was being
honest or not it was the worst he was
being a warmonger yeah he was basically
like well that's why we need war and
you're like is he people don't
understand you're joking bro like that
was a you you program people for a
decade have you watched his show I
nearly vomited for like 10 years
he wants money and he'll hide behind you
know whoever's John Stewart Jon
Stewart's Legacy is a plague on this
country
It Like Jordan klepper is his name or
whatever so you're not the B John Oliver
Stephen Colbert these are not good
people helping this guy you're the only
good alumni of The Daily Show or the
people who went into acting like Steve
Carell that's it right right yeah he
avoided political people avoided the
political stuff and he just did the
office and was and it's been funny for a
decade I mean Colbert was funny on The
Daily Show when he was the correspondent
I thought he's a funny actor but his
political crap is like just Oh I thought
Colbert Report is better than was better
than uh the current version of Colbert's
late night show which is just pure like
look at the most banal thing ever when
Jon Stewart went on Colbert's show the
new one and said that lab leak was the
most likely scenario for covid and
Colbert was pushing back like no no no
no no and that contrast right there was
the difference between what Jon Stewart
started and what beat what his legacy is
right that's true and you know he was
very busy also dancing with the syringes
so uh he was preoccupied and couldn't
really think straight there but you know
who who thought you know just being a
show for The Establishment it wasn't
paying off and I think
a big reason to to why this this is
happening is because probably Comedy
Central is running out of money and I
think they're going to move into the
same realm as yeah do they have anything
now I mean I guess they have South Parks
they have reruns of South Parks I guess
they don't even get original which are
now Premier premiered originally on on
Paramount plus uh so even even Comedy
Central doesn't have that so they're
probably going to be running just reruns
of old shows Tosh.0 uh and and just like
they have just like apple and Jon
Stewart I mean Comedy Central was like
the cable network absolutely yes and it
pushed the limit yeah especially with
Chappelle it pushed the Overton window
and it was able to have a conversation
that that was pretty spicy and wild you
know what this photo is compliance Daily
Show audience and what do you notice
about it masks what year is it yeah it's
2022 little Timothy take off your mask
what is going on with the daily shows
audience that they're all still doing
this and they're not laughing they're
closing and it's a cult yeah yeah this
is what a cult is
they they they're they're not following
the guidelines anymore they're in their
own weird cult yo the mass mandates are
gone what are you doing what's going on
man it's been almost two it's been oh
it's been over a year they're still
doing it crazy
well congratulations Jon Stewart you
know he he had us come back and he's he
dabbled in wokeness and stuff now too
because he people are just desperate for
relevance I guess I mean it must be sad
you know there's a lot of people who are
inside the music industry and they get a
handful of hit songs then the next album
comes out and it's like it sells
decently the next album comes out and no
one really cares and then their next
album comes out and it sells literally
nothing and they get dropped by their
label these people lost it they're so
desperate and scared that you offer them
anything they'll take it so reality TV
dancing with the chef it's like okay
you're gonna dance and this guy's gonna
cook food at the same time like I'll do
anything please I want to be famous the
natural trajectory of a internet come
here Harvey Weinstein like I said loudly
to his candidates the modern Superstar
does different things you don't keep
doing what made you famous when you were
young you got to go on to the next thing
make some hit songs make a hot TV show
learn Russian learn how to cook maybe
start a bread Baking Company like you've
got to do new things you can't back in
the day they just recycle the same
garbage but then they get unhappy and
then they start just playing the game to
play the game and they get lazy so
you've really gotta Branch Out and
because the reason you can do that is
because all the tools tools are at your
fingertips you can learn Russian tonight
you can start baking but you have access
to every food on Earth essentially right
now well a lot of people do I'm very
lucky to have access to every food on
Earth right now with a lot of them so
you may or may not I don't know but you
know you can that's not true look up
ingredients online you can look up
recipes you can start baking tonight
there's so many never been easier to
learn to cook I will say that you can't
get wasabi yeah most of it is scandalous
I think it's like you can only get it
actually in Japan they don't so we what
we have is like a weird I'm being
hyperbolic with every food on Earth but
you have a wide variety of foods to
choose from and recipes available at
your fingertips languages you can you
can learn how to Pilot with flight
simulators like right now you can start
learning the basics and then go take
your pilot's exam you're making me
hungry I want some wagyu beef hungry for
flight you made me think about Japan
cake with some vinegar baby well you've
not been here you just you know
I'm just waiting for that bacon to come
in so we ran out of the the pre-wrapped
bacon I had to order more but it takes
you know a week or so to come the reason
that came to my mind is like if Jon
Stewart did learn Russian and went to
Russia and started talking to is it like
a diplomat now we're talking the
international superstardom again and he
doesn't have to like hang on to Stephen
Colbert's coattails to try and stay
relevant and like say that the new cool
thing
but it takes a lot of effort to learn
new things you know there's no reason
that Jon Stewart couldn't actually be a
very interesting figure if he just
dispensed with the wokeness because I
don't think that's really him that
wasn't him in the 2000s at all he
praised project Veritas on more than one
occasion yeah I think you know and he
criticized people even Barack Obama and
his drone strikes which was rare and he
broke from the norm so whenever you see
someone trying to be accepted and be
liked that's just a disgusting behavior
that naturally human beings are like
okay this is fake this is ingenuine I
don't like any of this get away from me
but when someone's being themselves and
willing to push you know the envelope
and willing to be themselves and willing
to actually speak truth to power that's
respectable that's something that people
you know really love because it
resonates with them and it's rare but it
also helps progress society and make
Society better when you're willing to of
course get out of the agenda get out of
the narrative and be able to actually
have a real honest conversation and stop
bullshitting people about all this
nonsense that of course is all a part of
of an agenda meant to enslave Humanity
so yeah that's just my opinion at the
last time
my last bit there was just conjecture
there for for me but but you get the
point I'm sure look this is just the
story I think is is a white pill moment
it's optimism you know so I mentioned
this uh at the start of the show I did a
segment on this earlier the day uh
earlier in the day and I mentioned that
we are going to have one of the towers
on New Year's Eve so it's a substantial
amount of advertisement there's I think
10 ads that rotate over 100 seconds
we'll have one of those sets they're all
synchronized it's going to be amazing
and everybody who's watching the
celebration is going to see that ad
because they're they're playing a
celebration all day so it's just all day
all over the world everyone tuning into
New York City we are taking that space
over I don't see The Daily Show up there
you got to do a thing where it's just a
beanie and then you slowly materialize
into it and then you're there I mean
that'd be cool but I don't know if it
would like send an effective message I
make a message to me man that'd be
awesome I guess I was I was thinking
like you know one marketing strategy
would be to go weird by just doing like
using every ever every screen to show
Roberto Jr because then people are going
to be like what is this and then you
want them to ask and remember and then
yeah why is there a chicken up on a
giant fi you know what would that be
like 400 feet tall would it be all over
the building like his legs in one screen
like a piece of them and all the
different screens but if you stand back
far enough you can see the whole thing
the whole the whole chicken yeah but I
was like no maybe we'll just do you know
we had to figure it out but we want the
the personalities various personalities
got to do a super Super Bowl ad at some
point that would be absolutely insane we
yeah chickens playing football
right that'd be that'd be amazing a
cartoon but I think those are
substantially more expensive super Lads
are insane yeah but we could raise money
for it so like we weren't able to get
the actual package the uh I'll just tell
people like well maybe I shouldn't just
yet because I don't know what the
contract stuff is but let me just say
like there's a premium New York package
they have for specifically for New
Year's that includes like a national run
and it just costs millions of dollars
yeah and then when they called me and
they were like this is what we want to
do with with Tim cast and then I was
like wow how much is that and they were
like x million and I started laughing
and I was like okay dude like maybe next
year yeah maybe maybe one day I was like
but hey thanks for having faith and
thinking we're capable of doing those
things what we got is expensive but it's
it's like look we're getting 10 of the
of the of the boards so it's like not
like it's anywhere near that experience
you mentioned earlier but is it a
24-hour run on each board
all day every day for two weeks for two
weeks all day every day so we do a lot
of different stuff
yeah so technically you give them your
ad set and then they run it but you can
always send them updates because you do
how many like in a day different ones
can you run in one day I mean I'd
imagine as many as you want you to annoy
the crap out of them by telling them to
keep changing us they might be like come
on dude chill but uh we could do like an
update on Christmas because it's going
to be there through Christmas and then
on New Year's put you know something
updated for New Year's so you can
actually like what you're basically
renting the space and they're digital so
you can change them to whatever you want
do you like some hyperbox stuff like the
world is changing call to action of some
sort like stuff where like you are in
control it this is your world call to
action I think you know we thought about
doing some kind of message like you are
not the elite anymore or something but I
think the most effective thing is
literally just a basic ad thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there